all right my friends understand that
Florida has been caught hiding not
reporting coronavirus deaths and it's
absolutely sickening and it will lead to
more people dying for about ten days now
medical experts have been expecting
Florida's coronavirus deaths to spike
why well because Florida started
reopening beaches ten days ago they have
a totally incompetent Republican
Governor Ron de santis he's proven
himself to be absolutely clueless we
know Florida has the fifth oldest median
age in the country their population the
median age is the fifth oldest in the
country and coronavirus by a large
margin is disproportionately affecting
older people and yet the Florida death
numbers just like they never really got
that bad you look at the case numbers
they're not testing that much you see
about 33,000 cases okay that that's a
lot but for a state with more than 21
million people the case numbers are kind
of low that could just be testing but
then you see the deaths and somehow the
official coronavirus death toll in
Florida
was as of the moment where we looked at
it one thousand two hundred and
sixty-eight deaths now it would be
fantastic if that were the case it
didn't make sense the numbers just
didn't pass the sniff test given the
size of Florida and the policies and the
number of population densely populated
areas and now we have the answer Florida
officials have been withholding they've
just been not releasing the data from
medical examiners about coronavirus
deaths for more than a week now the hill
reports that Steven Nelson the chairman
of the state medical examiner's
Commission said to the Tampa Bay Times
the State Health Department intervened
and they told me they are going to
remove the causes of death in case
descriptions for mortality data which
will hold down the official death toll
from coronavirus in Florida now many
Republicans want to argue it's fine to
reopen shut downs aren't necessary they
support it by saying look we don't have
that many deaths here in Florida and yet
they're lying about the deaths they are
hiding the deaths according to this
report not only is this
disrespectful to people who have lost
their lives it's disrespectful to people
who seeing these fake numbers we'll go
outside instead of staying home will not
wear a mask instead of wearing a mask
we'll go in protest and lobby for
opening instead of understanding why it
is that we're doing what we're doing so
when you look at the measures that can
be taken to deal with the virus stay at
home orders closing businesses social
distancing masks what Florida has chosen
to do is just lie about the number of
people dying claim nobody's dying
it will also backfire by the way because
if you use fake numbers to support
opening up when you shouldn't that will
drive a crazy explosion in the number of
cases and deaths you would imagine
eventually it would get out no matter
what well here we have one report they
are blowing the whistle and saying that
the number is fake and it never made
sense on I'm trying to think if it was
on the show we're on live streams a week
and a half ago I was saying the the
Florida numbers should be spiking ok
heat and humidity may play a role in
slowing the spread but from the studies
we've seen it's only a minor role though
it only makes a little bit of a
difference where are Florida's deaths
what is going on and boom in comes a
whistleblower who says they're just not
reporting them if this is true and
there's every indication that it is it
is disgusting sick and it will lead to
even more death one of our sponsors
today is VIN Chara watches giving you
15% off your entire order when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch don't pay
thousands of dollars for a high-quality
watch that looks great because you don't
have to all of in Cera's watches are
made with high-end materials masterfully
built and they look like something you'd
spend a ton of money on but ever even
chera watch ranges from about a hundred
and fifty to three hundred bucks i went
over to their website and picked out the
bellwether and silver and white really
nice elegant look and a lot of people
ask me where's the watch from really
really great look totally different they
also sent me the altitude in matte black
and red a much more rugged view of what
a watch can look like really liked it as
well as well as the athletic strap it's
a new year it's a new decade it's time
to re-establish your style add something
new to your look and a high quality
watch is the perfect way to do that you
can get 15% off inch arrows entire
collection when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch